hallo liebe zwischen sie wärmen ich habe
heute einige auch nicht genommen
und wenn er eine fremde kultur bereits
circa 500 kilometer werden für mich im
rheinland und hier im rheinland
das bedeute für weimars marktwertes
karnevalistin können der straßenkarneval
in berlin oder anderswo in deutschland
ist das wie eine andere kultur und wir
wollen euch heute mal zeigen was ihr
passiert und unser thema des tages
deutscher humor los geht's
weil wir keine fragen offen wenn man
lachen kann
auch wenn es unsere freiheit ist was für
euch deutscher humor witze kennst du
bist ganz viele filme ein
jetzt fordern ok gehen zwei tomaten über
die straße sagt die eine zu einer kette
ab ja und hat noch ein also einer reicht
ja nun erste was uns auf kürzestem buch
der welt 1000 witze buch der deutschen
heute sagen immer die deutschen haben
keinen humor die müssen sie erst
verkleiden und betrinken damit
zusätzliche flüge komplett an karneval
ja aber wann ein krasses wasser die
rheinländer wenn die sie sind schon
anders als die richtigen deutsche oder
ja man spricht ihn in eine lockere
lebensart zu und das patriot gegangen
was man hier auch spielst du die liebe
zwar noch etwas schlapp aber hier und
tollen als flaschen hamburg oder berlin
da lacht man nicht sehr viele leute
sagen ja so die deutschen hang gar kein
humor stimmt dass humor haben sie schon
aber vielleicht nicht so elaboriert wie
in anderen völkern
ja es ist irgendwie macht sich das
bemerkbar naja sie finden wir vielleicht
auch etwas einfachere sachen lustig
macht es für dich deutscher humor das
ist kompliziert also deutscher mal ein
bisschen schwarzer humor aber das
komplizierte betrachten
ein bisschen müssen subjektiv betrachtet
überwältigt seine probleme solcher humor
wird in viele teile unterteilt es ist
einfach schwer deutschen humor als
spezifisch deutschen um neue dinge
darzustellen
jeder hat seine eigene präferenzen da
jetzt irgend wie jetzt schwarzer humor
sei jetzt irgendwie so angriff immer was
ein witziger weise dessen schwierigsten
war es schwer immer humor deutsch gott
was für eine frage
deutsche vor als wächter bisschen ja so
schlecht hat ihnen also keiner weil ich
persönlich eher ich wohne hätte mehr
leben für mich ist karneval kein ding
und andere oder anderes hat aber
irgendwie teil der deutschen solchen
brauchtums und der deutschen humors
liebe das meer zu beschreiben
ja ich brauche viele deutsche wie
brauchen man anlass nutzen zu sein
ja ja karneval
ich komme aus köln aber ich komme ich
auf dem belchen land
köln ich habe den kranken überhaupt und
war was machten hier im wald fragen was
ist üblich kölner humor und freizügiger
unterwegs
ein bisschen mit dichten ja schon witzig
da ist eine frage was würdest du sagen
zu jemand gesagt die deutschen dann
total ungepflegt die brauchen immer erst
alkohol und eine verkleidung und betrieb
zu sein
vedat überhaupt nicht
nein ich war in amerika und die
amerikaner als die herren humor
[Musik]
die deutlichsten locker lustig
verkleidete heute lange keiner
sie fangen um helfer mitbringen und
herren zwar wieder aufgefasst
das lieber amerikanische chicago oder
sonne von euch wird über amerikaner
stimmt hat was ihr keine habt wie haben
wir hier aber die kennt feiern
das sind zwei unterschiedliche dinge
das ist auch schon modisch ewigkeit wird
wie nennt man einen weißen hut helmut
playmate der blondine in der dusche hin
und herren warum weil auf dem shampoo
scheint groß ja vor zwei jahren als
becker leiter verkleidung
heute habe ich mir einen noch heftigeren
gekauft das ist mein kleiner potenziale
beiden im einfach hätte lieber filme
heute wenn die karte bände von england
wie würdest du den deutschen humor
befreien
ich hab ein jahr in deutschland verlegt
von daher habe ich ja gar deutsche
freunde und habe ich bin dann leider
auch nicht erneut verlängern sind wir
stolz dass mehr lustig bin würde ich
sagen genau also im park machen wir
einfach mehr wissen
sagen die ermittler ist die deutsche
jeder vierte satz eigentlich ein kleiner
westen aber lustig auf jeden fall aber
[Musik]
negative trockner mit unserem über die
deutschen brauchen so was offensichtlich
ist welche kostüme gibt marke kann kein
mathematiker witz erzählen leben am
limes unendlich und so aber häufig
brauchen die deutschen so ein anlass und
ich hab gerade weil es das beste
beispiel auf einmal wenn alle lustig wie
man sich von lachen miteinander und wenn
das wieder vorbei ist wir in vier tagen
ja dann wieder das aus für das wetter
gerade richtig los los oder die
deutschen brauchen um zu lachen und wenn
dann alle über den witz gemacht haben
dann ist auch wieder tote nicht in die
kneipe und sattel
wird ein vampir von der polizei
angehalten dann darf die polizei wir
haben noch getrunken hat nach der vampir
nur zwei radler jemand macht einen
kleinen satz rannte und sie können die
klassen zeigt der deutsche morgen schon
weh aber sie tun sich schwer mit dem
lachen angenommen wird für uns zu
anfahren im büro karneval kompanie
kulturen zu sagen alle feiern
miteinander und auch einfach nur spaß
freude pur
ja aber dem kölner wird ja nachgesagt er
kann ganz leicht fünfe gerade sein
lassen das kann er auch und also das ist
er lästert ebenfalls alles tun man kann
alles mitmachen vor allen dingen an
karneval und das ist das halt eben was
voneinander gerade an karneval
auszeichnen
ganz ganz schön hand mehr sagt er eine
high für andere deutsche humorist wenn
irgendetwas ganz unerwartetes passiert
und ein bisschen schlüpfrig ist eine
weitere episode über den deutschen humor
viel sie hast du heute was neues
erfahren über den deutschen zu wort
mit dem monatlichen betrag aber neu hast
du bei ihr sie wärmen hobby sonst eher
nüchtern feiern fennert wir haben es hat
euch gefallen wir haben euch einen
kleinen einblick gegeben in denen humor
hier in köln und vielleicht auch in
deutschland
wir werden auf jeden fall auf das thema
zurückkommen und wenn ihr übung machen
möchte
zu dieser 110 episode mit den neuen
vokabeln
dann könnt ihr hier unten ein patch
wären wir freuen uns sehr über eure
unterstützung und es bedeutet sehr viel
wenn ihr uns unterstützt damit wir unser
projekt weitermachen können danke schön
danke ihm sehr viel er geht die
kakerlake heute noch kannten ja klar
angeführt noch mit sanierten mal